this video contains major spoilers for
better call saul season 6 episode 3. if
you're interested in this character but
haven't made it that far then this isn't
the video you're looking for
you got in with both eyes open
my father didn't
he's got a gun to my father's head
better call saul's a story that's told
in a world where actions have
consequences and the systems that govern
how those are doled out make no false
promises of being just at the end of
episode 603 nacho varga is on trial
judgment will be passed based not on his
actions but because of the cumulative
nature of the choices he's made these
weren't about the pursuit of riches or
the accumulation of power but simply an
effort to make it out while at the same
time trying to keep his father safe in
the end nacho doesn't get out but he
does go out as the man he wanted to be
all men must die and there's no question
of death's inevitability in this case
but there are good deaths and there are
bad deaths in his final act ignacio
varga managed to secure himself a good
one although not in the way juan balsa
was suggesting he rose above the choices
being offered stayed true to what he
held to be most important and in
conjunction with an inspired performance
from michael mando solidified himself as
one of the series most memorable
characters that is no small feat
considering this thing is built on the
backs of a slew of fascinating
personalities most are of the variety
that resemble car crashes that you can't
look away from and what i love about
nacho is that he's a character you find
yourself starting to root for because of
the choices he's making this sets him
apart and the show managed to use this
to do some interesting things not least
of which was to construct a final scene
that manages to be intense even though
you know the fate of every other
character present in this his end feels
inevitable but you still find yourself
searching for a way things could turn
out differently he can't escape the
violent end that all of those present
will eventually know but nacho varga was
always different initially just because
he was one of a handful of characters
who don't appear in breaking bad but
there is much more to it in the first
season you're introduced to kim wexler
howard hamlin chuck mcgill and a variety
of side characters that all inhabit a
pre-heisenberg albuquerque about six
years before walter white is diagnosed
with cancer the problem with prequels is
you know how the story ends for the main
characters this makes for a great
situation for the unknowns and there
were big plans early on for nacho and
jimmy to be frequent antagonists then
there were some changes made to how he
would transform into soul and that
diminished nacho's role that's not to
say he didn't do anything important in
his introduction as one of tuko's more
reasonable associates he played a role
in saving jimmy's life only at that
point he seized on the information about
the kettleman's and tried to use that to
enrich himself he sort of faded into the
background from there and you wonder if
they named the third episode after him
more for the fact that his name fit the
convention of ending in an o rather than
how important he was to the story the
creators really liked the actor either
way so it was just a matter of time
until they found a way to utilize him
they realized that they could use his
uncertain ending to their advantage and
decided to make us like him that way if
they put him in danger there are stakes
in a way that there never can be for
characters like jimmy or mike this is
particularly effective since he's
surrounded by violent people but also
creates a challenge for making the
audience really care about him when
arturo died it was shocking because of
the method the way that it happened but
i think if you compare it to nachos
final moments you'll see how effective
this decision to make him different
turned out to be
it takes some time to develop though for
a while he continued to be a slightly
more palatable henchman compared to his
peers in the salamanca organization
right up until the moment he seeks
mike's help to make tuko go away he's
become erratic because of his using and
nacho worries that he'll come after him
if he doesn't make a move first mike's
code is stricter at this point in the
story and he doesn't want to kill anyone
this makes for an interesting
intersection of these two stories mike
is beginning his descent into this world
while nacho is starting to try to get
out and this adds to the gravity of the
situation they find themselves in later
he comes up with an alternate plan that
works but it also creates complications
and that brings tuko's uncle hector into
the equation things don't improve under
his new boss but he keeps his head down
until hector tries to use his father's
business as a front for their smuggling
operation his dad manuel varga is as
pure a character as this universe has
he's a normal citizen straight as can be
who works hard running his own small
business he's also a little proud and
very stubborn and because he doesn't
happily go along with the new plan don
hector doesn't trust him this makes
nacho fear for his life so he takes
drastic steps to try to take his boss
out the plan almost works and it would
have worked but gus intervenes because
he wants to decide how and when hector
will die this is all part of his quest
for revenge for the death of his partner
max and in the process of saving
hector's life he discovers what nacho
was trying to do which is information he
can use against him for his efforts of
trying to get out from under the
salamancas he's rewarded by being forced
to be a double agent for gus this has
him shot a couple of times to make up a
story to cover up what happened to
arturo things spiral when lalo enters
the picture to make things difficult for
gus who then resorts to threatening his
father's life and nacho realizes the
only way he can get out of this
situation is if he can get his father to
run away with him otherwise he'd never
be safe so by now it's clear that nacho
is no saint he made a choice to get
involved in the drug game in that he's
handed out beatings and even killed
people but where most people who found
themselves stuck in that position would
have just leaned in just went for the
money went for the power he went in the
other direction when faced with the
reality of who the people he worked for
were and of who he would become he
risked his life to become something else
and all of this made him sympathetic and
provided the story with a place where
tension can live because you just don't
know what's going to happen to him
unfortunately every failed attempt to
get out of the game left him in a more
compromised position he tried to set up
an escape plan that would include his
father and even tried to get mike's help
in relation to getting away from gus the
plan fell through when manuel refused
the offer on his shop because he figured
out that nacho was probably behind it
and probably using drug money and in the
wake of that they end up having a
conversation where he makes it clear
that he won't leave town i mentioned he
was stubborn and he lays it out there
that he won't accept anything short of
his son going to the police surely part
of this is him being naive not really
understanding what his son is up against
but there was another great decision in
the way they developed this in that they
made nacho the kind of character that
didn't want to put that burden on his
father he had so much respect that he
never gave him an ultimatum he wanted
him to decide for himself and when that
didn't happen nacho just tried to figure
out a different way to make it work he
won't be able to accomplish that and
this is where his story becomes
unflinchingly tragic he's forced to aid
gus in his failed attempt to take out
lalo because he could potentially expose
the chicken man's involvement both sides
want to kill him and it becomes clear
that he's down to just two choices he
could try to run knowing full well that
gus has already threatened his father or
he can forfeit his life to mislead the
salamancas pay the ultimate price not
for the mistakes he's made but for
something that would take suspicion off
of a person who's been torturing him
it's a hopeless situation but because of
the way the character's been developed
it makes complete sense that he would do
this in exchange for his father's safety
603 is nacho's episode it's his ending
and the name rockin hard place
encapsulates his story back against the
wall you see him strip down to his
essence and find out what's there a life
is decided through a series of choices
there's no control over how things play
out but in his time of judgment nacho
can choose who to be while many
characters would chase one last remote
or even irrational grab at survival
nacho varga chooses love for the one
pure thing left in his world a constant
in a chaotic unhinged existence like a
bright blue flower growing in the desert
it's not a perfect decision because
that's not how things work but it is a
perfect way to end his story
he's able to keep up his end of the
bargain by drawing suspicion away from
one tormentor and deliver a crushing
blow against the other there are no
guarantees only promises what matters in
the moment is that mike is the only
person he's grown to trust and he did
manage to end things on his own terms
i'd be remiss if i didn't mention
michael mando's masterful performance
again he brought the character to life
and his presence will be missed the
final phone call with his father will no
doubt be remembered as one of the most
heart-wrenching scenes in the series and
the adios papa just sticks with you and
i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know what you loved about
the character nacho varga and michael
mando's performance in the comments i
think the sheer impotence of hector
firing shots into his dead body is a
testament to what he accomplished and
i'd love to hear what you think please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon